لقد قررنا الآن الشروع في
التطعيم الإجباري على الصعيد الوطني
بسرعة كبيرة ، ومن المقرر أن يتم تطبيقه
اعتبارًا من فبراير الأول من عام 2022
، وأعتقد أننا جميعًا متفقون على أن هذه هي
طريقتنا الوحيدة للخروج من هذه الحلقة
المفرغة من موجات الفيروس و  أغلق
المناقشات مرة واحدة وإلى الأبد ،
لا نريد موجة خامسة ، لا نريد
موجة سادسة ،
وهذا هو إجابة السلطات النمساوية
التي كما أوضح خلال
ذلك المؤتمر الصحفي ، كانت تأمل
أن يذهب الناس للحصول على التطعيم.
باختيارهم في النهاية ،
سيضطرون إلى إجبارهم إذا كان الوباء
سينتهي ، لذا بحلول
الأول من فبراير ، ستكون النمسا الدولة الأولى
التي يتعين عليك فيها تلقيح
بموجب القانون  ارقام اه ما هو
التطعيم الصحيح اي الجيوب
بالدولة هي الاكثر استهدافا
الان من حيث كثرة
السكان الرافضين الحصول على اللقاح
جيدا وهي من أه
خصائص أه القيود
التي رأيناها في الأيام القليلة الماضية والتي
تم إدخالها في جميع أنحاء أوروبا
ليس فقط أنها تهدف إلى
استهداف غير الملقحين ولكن أيضًا أن
هناك اعترافًا بأن
بلدانًا بأكملها لا يتم ضربها بطريقة موحدة ،
على سبيل المثال  في ألمانيا حيث
تحدثوا عن حالة الطوارئ التي
يمرون فيها بعد 12 يومًا متتاليًا ، حيث
سجل ليندا ارتفاعًا قياسيًا في 19 حالة سرية ،
وهم ينظرون إلى تلك
القيود الجديدة في بعض أنحاء البلاد ولكن
في تلك المناطق التي لديها أعلى
نسبة حدوث
على سبيل المثال الوصول إلى الأنشطة الترفيهية والثقافية
لغير الملقحين